saying the quiet part out loud has been
sort of a theme of the trump
administration
and a huge cause of the constant
self-inflicted damage that donald trump
has done to himself has come from
saying things out loud or tweeting
things that he would probably be better
off keeping to himself
and it has unfortunately happened again
and in conjunction with the release of
his new book
called rage investigative journalist bob
woodward has
released audio of conversations that he
had
with donald trump during which a lot of
things happen
but making huge headlines is donald
trump admitting
that he publicly was not telling the
truth about coronavirus
as early as february for political
reasons now
there's debate as to whether they are
good political reasons or bad political
reasons i would argue it doesn't matter
that donald trump was deceiving the
public
and it wasn't a matter of national
security it was donald trump
wanting it to appear as though he had
things under control when he did not
let's go first to the clip and then we
will discuss it donald trump admitting
to bob woodward
that at the time february 7th his belief
about coronavirus was that it was very
serious even airborne
although publicly even for months after
this donald trump
never acknowledged coronavirus being as
dangerous as he admits
in this clip now it's turning out it's
not just old people bob which is today
and yesterday
some startling facts came out it's not
just old old
yeah exactly people to plenty of young
people so
what's going on give me an a moment
of talking to somebody going through
this with faushi
or somebody who kind of
it caused a pivot in your mind because
it's clear
just from what's in on the public record
that you went through
a pivot on this to oh my god the gravity
is uh almost inexplicable
and unexplainable well i think bob
really to be honest with you sure i want
you to i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic so there it is it's plain as day
now what is the response going to be
i'll tell you what it is it's not going
to be that the audio tapes
have been doctored because they clearly
have not the argument is going to be
not wanting people to panic is something
good
that donald trump does and it's
something that he has done in general
during his presidency of course
it is not true when it comes to the
immigrant caravan
donald trump's strategy was create as
much panic as possible
make people think things are as
dangerous as possible even when they are
not
when it comes to joe biden's america
the strategy is we want people to panic
because it's politically advantageous so
there are people
i don't know that they're all bad faith
actors but they certainly are making
nonsense arguments who are saying
this isn't bad this is trump saying hey
i don't want the country panicking so i
am going to do what i need to prevent
the country from panicking because panic
would be bad
that's not what this is donald trump has
no problem with the country panicking
when it is politically advantageous now
there's other clips here um in this next
clip
trump is talking to bob woodward again
and donald trump
uh continues to uh acknowledge
that the virus is airborne and it's far
more dangerous than donald trump ever
admitted and so
what was uh president xi saying
yesterday we were talking mostly about
the
virus and i think he's going to have it
in good shape but
you know it's a very tricky situation
it's uh
it goes it goes through air bob that's
always tougher than the touch you know
the touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's uh passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flues you know
people don't realize we lose twenty five
thousand thirty thousand people
a year here who would ever think that
right i know that
that's pretty amazing and then i say
well is that
the same thing for this is more deadly
this is
five per you know this is five percent
versus
one percent and less than one percent
you know so
this is deadly stuff now at the time
when trump said this to bob woodward
publicly
trump was saying it's like a seasonal
flu
it's going to disappear 15 cases will
soon be zero
it is a straight-up lie the only debate
is whether the lie was justified for
some reason i think the answer is
clearly no
other interesting things asked by bob
woodward
whether racism is here in the united
states in a way that affects people's
lives donald trump
replied i think it is and i think it's
unfortunate
but i believe it is i don't think there
is systematic or institutional
racism in this country well i think
there is everywhere i think probably
less here than most places or less here
than many places
okay but is it here in a way that it has
an impact on people's lives
i think it is and it's unfortunate but i
think it is
so trump admitting there something that
again
he has refused to acknowledge publicly
and overall
this is a wild book all sorts of
stunning material from bob woodward
we're going to talk later about
uh the report in this book that donald
trump's former secretary of defense jim
mattis
said to the director of national
intelligence dan coats that they may
need
collective action to remove donald trump
we're going to talk later about whether
bob woodward had a responsibility
to make some of these elements public
sooner than he did
we're going to get to all of that but
the top line the big
story that there are even legal scholars
saying is an impeachable offense
although it's a question mark for me
what do i know but really the top line
is
donald trump knew how serious coronavir
coronavirus was back in february early
february
and he didn't acknowledge it publicly
ostensibly claiming it's to avoid
causing panic but we know how that
worked out
tens of millions of americans to this
day still don't think
this is a serious pandemic because of
that early denial campaign
by donald trump and meanwhile and
tomorrow i'm going to get to this
there's just so much here
meanwhile donald trump's approval
in all likelihood is going to remain
around 45
because something is very wrong with our
country donald trump is admitting
i pretended it was less serious which
led to
more death than necessary and approval
is not
likely to budge very much it's amazing
it's it's amazing in terms of the
indictment that it is
of our country anybody in my view who
has not left donald trump already
is probably not going to leave him
because of this but i don't want to get
ahead of myself we're going to get into
that tomorrow now meanwhile
you have and we'll discuss this on the
bonus show today
donald trump is arguing that he should
be considered for the nobel peace prize
and in fact
a far-right norwegian politician has
nominated him for it
on the other hand we are wondering
whether his handling of coronavirus
counts as a crime against humanity
that's how disparate the country is
right now
on the issue of donald trump now just
just
one sec i want to go back again to the
explanation that is the predominant one
in response to this audio which is
donald trump didn't want to cause panic
that's a good reason to downplay the
virus
that is barely better even if you
believe it i don't believe it because
donald trump has no problem causing
panic as i said
when he judges it's politically
advantageous immigrant caravan
anarchists in the streets joe biden's
america
you'll have a depression like you've
never seen before trump is fine causing
panic when it's good for him
but imagine that it is true that donald
trump didn't want to panic
americans we had more death than we
needed
because americans weren't panicked in
other words americans
panicking or what i call taking it more
seriously
would have saved lives and the next few
weeks could see all sorts of tapes
coming out
there may be more bob woodward tapes
michael cohen may have tapes
there are all sorts of tapes that could
be floating around but again
really will it matter tomorrow on the
program i will argue
no and we will get to that but
first let's talk about some of the other
allegations
in bob woodward's book if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video